welcome to the dark forest Jackie and
applause will therefore for us shameless
confession about our obsession with it
cuz laugh and smile six more the dark
forest north bound for its Jackie
Kashian welcome to the dork forest you
know the websites Jackie Kashian calm
dark forest comma on iTunes I'm on all
things comedy calm you could donate at
Jackie Kashian kamar dark forest calm
you can buy merch t-shirts and CDs and
what not and also see where I'm doing
stand-up comedy and I have an ad this
episode so I say let's get into it right
after the credits Mike Rick were
composed and sang that song he will sing
his lyrics to the Mexican Hat dance at
the end of this episode Patrick Brady
will fix this audio thank God and Vilmos
does my website Jackie Kashian calm and
now the ad hello Rangers I was sent an
awesome set of sheets from parachute
home.com and so I'm gonna do an ad about
it because they sent me some awesome
sheets and i love i love sheets quite
honestly parachute home.com is an online
betting company from Venice California
right here in the Los Angeles area they
have a hundred percent long staple
Egyptian cotton bedding my favorite kind
of bedding quite honestly because that
whole remember when the thread count was
a scam I read an article is that it can
only go up to 450 thread count and then
they're doing a crosshatch and then it
just it isn't quite as soft anymore so
these are great sheets you guys they
really are there milled and Tuscany
they've been milling sheets for 80 years
in Tuscany and they parachute home they
ship it right to your door so it cuts
out the middleman there are a lot
cheaper than equally fancy sheets that
have to go through some sort of weird
middleman I spent a bunch of money one
time on some sweet sheets and they're
great but these are just as good and
there are about a hundred and fifty
dollars less for the set of sheets and
when I say a set of sheets I'm talking
about a fitted sheet full size by the
way Andy and I do it some cuddling full
size sheet flat sheet and
two pillowcases they were like a million
dollars and they were great they are
great they're beautiful sheets I love
them a lot these are just as great and
you can get a deal from the dork forest
if you go to parachute home.com / dork
you get twenty five dollars off your
first order that's right and it's
exciting I'm a sleeper because I do
stand-up I like to get somewhere between
eight and thirteen hours of sleep at
night so enormous sheets you guys and
these are super they're soft but they're
not weirdly fuzzy they're just cotton
soft super cozy parachute home.com they
asked me to weigh in forty percent of
Americans I guess sleep without a top
sheet and what do I think of that I'll
tell you what I think of that I think
they're animals I think that they're
animals and it isn't okay because we
didn't have a top sheet when I was a kid
but I lived a different life when I was
a child I don't know why we didn't have
top sheets but I recommend a top sheet
especially a warm climate where you're
just going to want to use the top sheet
other than that I went to their website
to see if i get if it was easy to order
it is it is easy to order the color I
picked was slate just so you know
they're a local company here in Los
Angeles and they also they are a good
company they give back they partnered
with the UN foundations nothing but nets
campaign so they donate to provide
malaria prevention bed nets all around
the world so they're good people they
make a heck of an ice sheet and you can
get twenty five dollars off on your
first order if you go to parachute home
calm / dork there it is let us start the
show hey it's Jackie Kashian I'm in my
living room with David kettner welcome
to the program David thanks for having
me it's it's the dork forest it took two
years for us did test finally I think it
might be too plus I didn't check exactly
that email laying right or thread but it
was young it was a long time but as I
said it often takes me or us two years
to have dinner with people right right
you will you have a large large
sprawling family of many Kettner's we
got five kids five kids that will go out
into the world
and make more oh boy oh boy how many
boys how many girls I've got two boys
three girls oh wow yeah and how does it
break down oldest Charlie's the oldest
okay and that's a boy Margo is the neck
Charlie 16 Margo's 13 twins sergeant and
Audrey or nine and Eve is for Wow twins
that'll do it yeah that'll that'll add
to the to the numbers the chaos yeah but
I like that it was a boy and a girl and
then you're like he's gonna get actually
went boy girl yeah boy girl boy girl
within two minutes Yeah Yeah Yeah right
so people David character you know him
from us a song in the story but you can
go to at David kettner for twitter which
is KO e CH n ER and then it's just David
Hector com stand-up comic a hilarious
actor guy you know these things people
don't people do your work is what I via
then they know my face may know you
write them know my work they they have
they struggle with my last name and I'm
my guesses people struggle with your
last name to all the time all the time
yeah it's I always I never cared
question online you just starting to
show business you don't know right and
until years later is like oh I should
have just rectified that either just
changed it right tu que es H n er rip
education er which is more in line with
the German or just made it ke ckn ER cuz
people they just get they get koe and
then they punt oh that's it is it it is
German though it is German but I'm not
German my grandfather was adopted okay
and so he was who would DNA thing and
find out what you were well we we traced
it back to a no an orphanage in in New
York okay and we don't know if it was a
single mother or if it was a broken
family let's see he was not he was not a
newborn ok I just talked to my sister's
about this cuz we just recently had a
family vacation he's a couple years old
okay you know he wasn't brand new and so
we don't know of a situation where he
was there at the orphanage for years
right worth them if the mother finally
had to just get rid of him it was you
know just passed the turn of the century
right okay and then he there's either a
Williams or a Howard and we don't know
if that was father mother whatever oh
that was on the paperwork yes okay but
you can tell by the power of my skin
yes that I'm Irish my mother in
solutions translucent yes yes my mother
was a Downey okay last name was Downey
hmm her mother was an O'Conner okay
that's full i rekon that side and i
suspect that maybe it was a williams on
my grandfather's side we should make it
further anglican of the Anglo well I
think it's that it's that it's that
mutley of Northern European or Northern
I upper to Giles kind of thing Andy
ashcraft my fella he's he's a big
Muttley guy if you asked him what his
ancestry was he would say well we're
from Mississippi right and you're like
well that what about before then he was
like well it's been a long time do I
believe it's Welsh and Irish and brit
you know english and i love but the the
provincial attitude from the south it's
that's where i'm fairly the south yep
you don't need to know anything more
than I've work your Mississippi yeah
what do you told me that I was like okay
I'm Armenian and then on the other side
I'm Irish and Norwegian yeah and but I'm
from Wisconsin and there's a lot of
Germans and a lot of sweets and young
and a lot of you know that yes
everywhere yeah but in but does it is a
very southern thing I've been dipped of
a dip tints of Southern culture because
both his entire family is from this
small town in opposite of Tupelo yeah
well how small um we're not as small as
that little town in Missouri you're from
Jordan Tipton um it's called New Albany
I don't know how big it is but it's got
one espresso machine a lot of people
left albany has said this doesn't it no
no we gotta get it sized out we're gonna
downsize yeah it's gonna do all the
first of all and I don't wanna be
disparaging to your listeners that might
be from Mississippi but you know to say
to declare you from Mississippi is
something you never have to do no no a
lot of maybe it's something you should
just keep yourself that's not nice you
know his his young cousin who we he
joined the Marines to get out of New
Albany but now has a lot of nostalgia
for New Albany said right yeah what's
funny about about young andrew is a he
joined the Marines and he had joined the
Marines at his mom his mama said to me
will you put over to Iraq why don't you
should tell him did not to join the
Marines I said well as he signed the
papers and she goes yeah and I said too
late too late my friend and I turned to
him and I said you know what my dad
always
told my brother's is that you can join
the service but you know you can also
just leave you leave the house you could
just you could leave town you can go get
a job shoveling sand for 250 an hour
anywhere in the world you don't need to
join the service to do it and my dad had
joined the service yeah it was in the
Navy and the Marines at all this let's
see what year was your dad in the
service Oh heat my father is a genius of
timing he was in from i believe it was
5460 that's when my dad was there he
missed everything yep right after Korea
am I get this somebody it now our
parents were probably roughly the same
age yep and so yeah that's just a matter
of course that's what you did he wasn't
drafted no but that's what all he's from
a family of nine there were five boys
and soaked every one of them except the
last one joined the service what is the
youngest 20 the other war was over it
was before Vietnam and he just worked on
the farm than the he and then he just
got did good yeah just yeah my dad
joined because he got my mom pregnant
Wow and he was the only child he was an
only child and and then he had six kids
okay suddenly on the Angus 26 I'm the 36
there you go there you go and but he was
so funny about my dad cuz he heard about
Vietnam that's when he didn't Rio long
as my father has always said he said I'd
rather be called a coward than an idiot
Wow he was a medic and he says was a
pressure him to stick around for another
four years they knew he had at the time
he had four kids and they were like well
you should probably stay with your kids
and he was like I should probably stay
yeah so he's in 1960 we had not we were
only funding the French at the time
right but he had heard about like us he
was in the marines and either word if i
weren't you yeah there were a bunch of
visors advisors who were shooting at
people and being shot at boy we wanted
in that war so badly so we had to make
up an excuse to get in cuz where did you
hit me did you push me you push me like
no no we wouldn't push you yeah
unbelievable it was yeah it's completely
insane so let's talk briefly about the
David Kenner dork num which kind of
leads into it a little bit because you
like nonfiction you like I do like
nonfiction it's it's cuz I in my opinion
people read either fiction or nonfiction
shorts in if you like fiction is short
stories or
novels and if you like nonfiction
sometimes you can get into short fiction
do you ever do short fiction when it's
fiction I love short stories yeah and if
anybody can help me this there was a
compilation there's something I'm still
searching for words to this day
compilation was in sixth grade of
fiction and I can't remember I've looked
and looked and looked Kurt Vonnegut or
um might be Vonnegut it might be
hyndland it might be um gosh darn it
help me I'm Vonnegut or uh Gibson
william gibson Vonnegut there's Robert
Heinlein know the other famous science
fiction writer okay from Vonnegut era
yeah uh it's a sorry it's that's okay
what is it uh what kind of uh Harrison
Bergeron was that Vonnegut I Oh anyway
so that's it was it wasn't them the
rotor but it was a compilation of short
stories of American fiction and there
was a short story about a guy who was a
mild meek accountant with a very stern
wife and he always every night he would
go to the bar or gin mill of some kind
okay and play piano yeah and um you know
it's a place where he could witness his
life that his he and his Christian wife
would never allow okay them to go turns
out he had tons of money saved but he
didn't want to tell his wife cuz he
loved going playing piano at this bar
yeah and I've looked and looked and
looked I can't find the compilation and
I don't know that story I've looked
under gin mill I looked under the piano
all kinds of things I've looked for
Vonnegut Vonnegut in compilations right
right so--okay so want to get wrote
Harrison Bergeron yes that's why that's
what I was trying yes and and Todd
Masson or Mary Ellen for getting your
last name sorry who's a librarian who
listens to the show somebody emailed me
uh Jackie Jackie Kashian com I'm also
you're yelling at your ipod right now
another story in this compilation was
the contender which was about a young
african-american boxer who ended up
going wrong I don't think it was James
bald and I don't think was a Baldwin
short story but I'd uh that was among
the things in the Appalachian okay so we
get back to my grade school in that
sixth grade classroom requires I know
you're still reading the same books yeah
I'm sure though I'm sure they are
because it was such a fascinating short
story and I remember loving it so much
and I can't remember the name
but because details always escape me
right but I thought that short stories
one you could turn into a movie right
well you know and and that's do you ever
do that i mean i do that ever since
moving here you read things and go well
why isn't that a film right it's I have
said it before on this program but there
is a great shuts a trilogy but only the
first one needs to be it be it it would
be bigger than blade runner I don't know
if that's true but it was called when
gravity fails and who wrote that George
Alec Effinger okay and it is essentially
it's a hard-boiled noir mystery novel
set in a futuristic mumbai in the red
light district oh my gosh which is now
yeah which is it and everyone's muslim
laps muslim were devout muslim but super
awesome and it's a cool story it is a
cool story but I you know in today's
climate you know you think about the
recent attack on Sony right perhaps
because of the interview all right can
you imagine the outrage in the Muslim
world wait if they were to I've space
the the the what was the interview Oh
Seth Rogen okay oh well the movie the
interview yeah that's right and if you
were to suggest that a future Muslim
world included a red light district yeah
which I'm sure there exists anyway it's
just so it's everywhere yes of course so
there was you know when I was uh uh when
I was in Iraq we stated and I was just
performing for the troops right so we
were staying in Baghdad and the went
Baghdad yeah in his uh in in Saddam
Hussein's no compound we stayed at his
guesthouse and I've already covered this
on your show no okay come on it but you
thought you're gonna interview me well I
know what the hell just happened we're
no no wait wait wait wait wait that's
fascinating what year did you do it well
it was in 2009 I wish it were still only
those thick of it it was it was a it was
a dumb year to go but I went with scott
kennedy remember scott kennedy he wore
FUBU uh jerseys and he was a big guy but
he was gay and and he was a comic AIDS
hung out at the improv a lot drank a lot
of whiskey good egg passed away by the
two years ago but he went he brought
comics two different comics every month
for 42 I think was a
42 weeks in a row god bless him yeah god
bless him and he would take people to
forward operating bases and whatever jss
stands for yeah he was like the only
reason I went was because he went every
month Wow and he knew who to call if
there was trouble yeah so i could get
lured so I'm recently married right and
I was like I don't know how to not do
this and Andy's like be great if you
called every day yeah and so I got I got
asked to you know several times yeah and
not even to Iraq but I said no every
time because because he you have a huge
family knows your secret I can do yes so
wait a minute okay your state at the
guest house and the guest house was
attached to his sort of cäcilie compound
thing several things about Saddam
Hussein that uh that even the Iraqis
would say well this was good that it
wasn't there i mean granted a hundred
thousand dead later right now I mean I
don't know what I don't know how you
know what twenty-twenty hindsight
whatever but he had diverted most of the
drinking water to create these ponds
you're kidding yeah to make this because
there is a part of the Muslim of faith
in islam you can you can get someone to
tell you you can get it a mom to tell
you that uh that if bad things happen
surrounded by water Allah doesn't care
are you kidding so there was like a
[ __ ] house in the middle of this pond
his mother-in-law was in the middle of
this pond or his mom I forget there was
like things there were horrible
buildings in the middle of these
different ponds and um you know the the
whorehouse was there were they were very
young young girls and it was bad so it
was but you would so there are
definitely red light district sir but
they're definitely right people people
are getting laid it turns out Muslims
are getting laid yeah even in very
strict Islamic country where they're not
supposed to drink and they're not
supposed to smoke and they're not
supposed to do things right I think they
can smoke but but the but things are
happening um how was it sleeping over
there it was it was well it was scary
just because I you know I'm not soup I
don't have I don't have I'm not
particularly courageous but I'm not that
twitchy and
because of of scott kennedy it was I
knew that he knew what he was doing but
we get there and it's all dust storms
it's the following in July those are
supposed to be yeah it's the first week
of July which it was genuinely 121
degrees you couldn't was hard to breathe
in Kuwait when we landed cuz you'd fly
commercial to Kuwait right then you fly
military from Kuwait to Baghdad and the
we tried to fly in a Baghdad but it was
there was a dust storm which way to turn
around but in that way you try to fly
where from from Kuwait to be in the
military plane what kind of plane it was
like it was one of those cargo yeah true
oh my god plan and they were like oh
that's too it's too windy so we're going
back to Kuwait Wendy or two too much of
a sandstorm it was a sandstorm did you
see it from your plane I couldn't I
didn't see there's no was we were above
that well there was no I was in the
cockpit huh it was awesome I was saying
it was awesome i was in the cockpit and
they were they were they the pilots
drank these tiny little kind of redbull
things that I I drink pots of coffee a
day and the pilot strike you want to try
to they're great the enlisted guys are
always trying to get us to give them cuz
if you join the service by the way i
would recommend this if you're thinking
of joining the service air force way to
go you got all the air conditioning they
have they have ice cream machines it's
great take care of the pilots yeah they
take care of ya was it it was different
than what we know of a 5-hour energy
drink it's it's something else what
you're somebody else those five hour
energy drinks are only three ounces this
thing was like eight ounces or six
ounces and it was a soda but it was an
orange and it was I was just trippin I
was buzzing like a crazy person I
wouldn't have another you an F no no I
would not I don't even are you a redbull
drinking or drink red but already knows
it's not for me I don't think I think
there was a window when sort of a mike's
hard lemonade like if you're missed out
on your like I think I drank zimas yeah
and that was that was more the shitty
drink of my youth so whatever but these
pilots are drinking it for what reason
to stay energized her to stay up because
they unfortunately they're flying too
much so wait a minute now you're in a
plane a military plane flying into Iraq
heading into a sandstorm and the the by
the mere fact that these pilots are
offering
this drink you know that they're on it
and they are fatigued right they very
easily could be fit but they all seem
good so there's you know there's two
pilots and then there's a navigation guy
and then there's a kid that keeps
running is served for PA just keeps
running back and forth bringing them
stuff and then Scott and the other comic
who was Nate bargatze okay remember that
guy okay very funny cut anything
remember that guy is give you everything
I know I haven't oh okay so you said
remember like like no passed away as
well nope naper can see good egg great
guy still working and so but they were
down in the in the belly that the ship
with the the plane why did you why did
you get the cockpit because they they
let cuz ok so we've cuz you're a lady
just I was a lady I got to go first and
then uh the other thing i got was i got
my own tent we were in the Forward
Operating Base wait I got VIP tents what
are you talking about because you went
to the forward-operating area yeah yeah
because and we couldn't fly anywhere we
were supposed to fly in these amraam
these uh helicopters right and group
transport helicopter you know that the
the the fighter ones yet a fighter ones
but I said the fighter ones your
masculine we don't Blackhawks that's it
I think when they were black hawk good
me and never one of the reasons i went
to cuz i wanted to fly in a black are
you crazy why those are a target right
but they would not i don't know anyway
so but i I've never flown a helicopter
over Florida yes what it meet it was
neat and I will I will yes although once
it wasn't that a couple times well
didn't do the Grand Canyon one did you
know although never do here's what it
was talladega nights and right now we
were we were let's see I drove there
with Ian Robertson Jack McBrayer and it
took several hours from where we were
staying cuz that's an Alabama which is
next to Mississippi right shout out to
Mississippi yeah Gulf Coast we hope it's
getting better and so drove there will
it choppered in a ball and adam mckay
and their manager had choppered in I
driven it took several hours we got a
police escort once we got close I forget
if we were we flew from somewhere than
we chop it with drove to Talladega so go
there now on the way back the choice was
truck back out or
hey Kepner we've got an extra seat on
the chopper and it's a pretty big one so
it's me will Adams adamek a adams evans
McCabe's and jim miller and then Michael
Clarke Duncan was going to come with us
yeah and then myself and God rest
Michael but was he uh-huh he's past oh
my god yes all right but once we're
about to get on in the chopper yeah he
got in and they got out and said no okay
that's not fair yeah you can't cuz now
they have to drive you somewhere fancy
no no cuz you can't buddy holly me oh
there you go let's say yes and then the
guy that said no and you're gonna live
and then yeah it's like way and that
that put me that gave me a great deal of
unease so but then we were chopping like
so four seats in the back and two seats
in the front and but it was fine
possibly it was a bit harrowing right
it's well and it was was it opened ord
no no no closed doors your Black Hawk
open doors we didn't get to fly black
ops we had to drive through Iraq in
Humvees huh in like these MRAP things
he's mine resistant armored personnel
knows yeah yeah and we got lost and
Idaho DPS well the hilarious thing is
said this is a true story I tell it in
my act but the navigation guide this
guide munos the iphone doubt we were
lost because we were all on headphones
and whatever and and he goes the
sergeant says why are we lost who knows
why we lost at munos because everyone's
hilarious and war zone said this were
mapquest sent a search no funny stuff
funny stuff moon are you wearing body
armor i am i'm wearing I'm wearing a
Kevlar thing good helmet oh my god but
and then shorts ah cuz it's a hundred
twenty this is 120 even in the am wrap
which was air-conditioned it was still
an 85 90 degrees a bad word so edit well
you're cracking jokes all the way cuz
that's your job well and it was the
driver guy the the moon eosin advocator
guy there was a kid sticking out the
blowhole no with a bit that is a gunner
a gunner dude well and the
there's I mean I'm the truck with Scott
there's videos on my youtube page of me
shooting us driving through Baghdad and
inside the MRAP how many kills uh get
any kills okay uh but everyone like
literally there was it was it was scary
like when we were we were on the hump of
this irrigation ditch and Iraqis we
would drive by him and they would point
and go how the hell did they get up
there but we don't even know how we and
then when you has had to get out of the
truck at one point and direct us over uh
and he genuinely he goes that's where
the bad guys are oh my god and but and
and I tell the story but it's it's you
know in them when you work at a
restaurant and someone throws up in the
bathroom more than or the club right and
then the manager comes out and everyone
freezes and he picks someone and then
that person goes [ __ ] yeah and grabs a
mop and a bucket Rose cleans it up so
the sergeant on the headphones goes
someone has to get out of this truck and
direct us over this dirt bridge and all
like we were in a 3m rap convoy and I
swear to God I can hear the silence from
the other two mr apps but that silence
over the phone everyone just froze that
was the worst part yeah and we I was in
the front one and he goes munos it has
to be you cuz you're the only one as a
door so he gets out and he directs the
zoo the thing and but he had to get out
three times Wow and he did it every time
and that was when I realized that being
in the army was a job a shitty day job
oh my god and raising where we are where
we gigs the UH they were outside of it
was right after we said that we were
pulling out of Baghdad and we did we
pulled out a baguette and built all
kinds of nonsense right outside of
Baghdad so it was just a political move
to say see we're retreating where we're
giving the the city back to their people
right and we were but it was very you
know it was just one step in the right
what we built a pentagon there yes it's
a it's our embassy yeah but it's it's
huge and multi fortified right yeah it's
a it's a giant fort and it's but it was
yeah i was i would think it's much like
the wild west when we would go out there
and build these stick forts right an
Indian tear
right indigenous territory right and
which is exactly what that's what I'm
players do yes we go to we go to places
that aren't ours and we build outposts
boy we are spoiling for a fall we well
you know I off above off I I've often
thought this do you think you know
during the fall of Rome that everyone
was sitting around comparing the fall of
Rome thinking you know I wonder if back
when Egypt was falling if they all knew
that it was it was the end yeah because
i think you know when things are in
decline yep you know that it's not well
rome was death by a thousand cuts oh
there's a bunch of dogs biting
everywhere and they just couldn't do it
they expanded too far but we've done the
same thing it's a it's cuz that's the
only way to get rid of an empire we have
standing armies everywhere there are
10,000 American soldiers in the world
about no no Oh many many different
places I don't know if we still
different 10,000 yes oh my god we used
to have 10,000 a jerk in those gigs yet
right now right I know you know we have
a huge contingent in Japan okay
contingent in oh right North Korea not
I'm sorry South Korea a huge contingent
in are they we used to I'm sure we have
10,000 men in Europe all over Europe and
I remember taking a class like a
poli-sci class in college and they said
you know the reason we have 10,000 men
here or there that's not to defend
anything it's to give us the excuse to
go in right we checked that soil for a
minute to we get everybody else there
yes if you take one of my pawns yeah now
that no war well and now this is this is
I was talking with it with Annie about
this because the isis or isil or
whatever then that the group that keeps
they're doing their very much doing
conquering in an old-school kind of
Genghis Khan kind of Kings con Visigoths
yeah yes because the way we take over
things is we just build a fort and say
that we're helping right the way they're
doing it is they're raising their just
burning everything to the ground and
then they are rebuilding the water
treatment plant and then they're like
they're starting schools but they're all
super conservative doctrine ations yes
they're starting a you know it's very
much it's
exactly like the Romans it's not like
whoa tried and true right it's so old
school that everyone's like well it's a
terrorist organization of like no no
this this I mean I'm terrified it's wait
that's done that's the way it's always
been done was it this noose this new way
is new yeah but it's it's it's the old
way which was at the Huns or the
Visigoths or the the Mongols possibly i
would put the heads of defeated armies
on spears right and carry those into
battle to strike fear into right
whatever our army they're going up
against which is exactly what isil's
doing beheading laying around yep and
getting is showing people the heads and
going this is what heads look like
television is the tip of the spear yeah
it's the same thing yeah this is what
we'll do to you it's just super creepy
uh backing up first of all have you seen
a show on PBS called genealogy roadshow
no it is wait is that the one word
Roadshow okay but by the same people who
did an antique roadshow but for regular
people I'll look up your genealogy huh
and they could trace you back to Genghis
Khan well mine I know where r we've
researched we know where our stops
obviously like my grandfather stops in
New York did you do DNA to know cuz they
do DNA and they can bring you back to
France in the seventh century how far
you want to go bring that beat back
bring all you want to go back brother
want to go back I do to you yeah uh and
in that we go back to Ireland on my
mother's side right then in Ireland that
the church rather the records were kept
in the in churches mm-hmm and the church
where our ancestors records were kept
burned Oh fair enough so yep that's how
it's fascinating how we have this desire
to know right right and and Americans
usually just want to go back to when we
got here and but other like what they
did one not not genealogy roadshow but
when they do them in other countries
people want to go back to you know weird
the pre like you see ya we're gonna go
back on it so but um and we're not
talking about the television show folks
if you don't just Google Lucy Liu yeah
Lucy is the supposedly
the first noticed well the oldest known
skeleton I think they recently found one
a little bit older it's nice that they
didn't name or Eve right and that's my
youngest daughter's me name oh really oh
pretty yeah that's nice it's let's talk
about some of these sent okies books
you're like the Wright brothers so you
you try to read too many books at once
yes I like to overwhelm myself I sense
that cuz we're like 25 minutes in and
you've talked about 19 things so yeah
it's perfect it's at least I'm
interested yep and interesting well all
of it that's arguable so what are you
reading right now are trying to read
well you've got your list i'm reading a
uh i guess a biography essentially of
the wright brothers okay um mccullough
is the author author and i loved his
1776 he narrates it wonderfully was it
audible know the one i'm reading is not
an audible but i probably should have
made it because i really enjoy his
narration and i really enjoy his writing
oh so that's why i picked that one up
and he report on about 1776 yes it's
fabulous and that's one to listen to i
love it okay um he's got this really dry
delivery but it's just lyrical enough
and it's he's so you could tell there's
such confidence and engagement in the
way he's doing it i loved it i would i
used to listen to it when my son Charlie
who's now 16 was in grade school and he
would listen on the way to school yeah
and he wouldn't demand a listen to all
of it which is okay yep but the years
later somehow you know you down
accidentally all I think I'd put it in
the van accidentally you can always do
it do it ation yeah yeah and the kids
had learned the first stanza of like the
5th or 6th chapter oh when I was was
this the troops were in good spirits and
so they all know because they then we go
away with a wrong song wrong song right
yeah so so that's why i picked up the
Wright brothers because I find him at a
fascinating an engaging writer and I
love history yeah as well and what else
is on the list well so so 1776 was
clearly just a a history of sort of the
Revolutionary War okay so edit and the
start of it did it start before 72 yes
and go through 81 or what do they do
gosh I can't remember or do they just go
through the deck lore
dependence you know what I can't
remember so was that when they wore are
actually yes very now then the yes they
do he goes through the end of the war
okay yes and the mistakes essentially
just a anthology a historical
perspective of the war yeah oh that's
neat and personality driven that's my
favorite kind of history oh yeah you you
get to learn all the major players and
who the heroes were and you know they
when you think about it's really
remarkable when you think about these
people who are part of a young nation
yeah who left their farms to fight for
this country mm-hmm and they would go
barefoot yeah I you're leaving your
livelihood I mean how many of us today
won't bother to do anything but check
Twitter that's it I mean that's our
level of engagement are you can't pick
up a gun and fight for your country
thank God people do like your your
nephew but well that's what I was gonna
tell you about him by the way is that
he's yeah he wanted to be a spot he
wanted to learn Arabic and go to
monterey and learn arabic and become a
he's in the marines he wanted to be a
recon marine and and and do all this
stuff and when he got out of boot camp
he was he was I said so how do they
how's it coming and he actually said he
said the Mississippi public school
system has not done me any favors he
said I mean I'm in a recon group I don't
know if he's on a recon gurram but he
said I'm with kind of a spy or an
intelligence group but I Drive the truck
and he said such a hard truck to drive
its kind of antsy truck munos yeah he's
munos yeah so yeah but um yeah I mean
the fact that that that anybody's
willing I mean we're not even willing to
go do sit-ins or marches and things like
that anymore I mean when you think about
the Sidon is a classic American kind of
thing from the 60s where a post-world
war two kind of way of protesting
something yeah I'm gonna sit here no
you're gonna have to pull me away from
this and now anytime that we can't even
do that any group that organizes gets
all kinds of negative media attention
occupy got nothing but negative media
attention now black lives matter yeah
get all kinds of it's astounding to me
for no reason then we just no one says
anything we okay you're gonna you're
gonna shut that one down okay where it
will be fine with it
you know Fox News or whoever those
agents are they haven't been able to
destroy move on from the move on must be
savier than that I guess but I don't
hear a lot from them oh I'm on their
mailing other severe there is not exist
they're non-stop i know i had done scrub
sorry I gotta tell you I had it say no
more yeah yeah cuz it was three or four
a day right it was well it isn't that
money anymore who's working over there
he is bored I still subscribe to the
nation so I get theirs as well yeah i'll
do i'll do i'll do their bidding a
friend of mine gave me a subscription to
the progressive and I've never renewed
it and they keep sending it to me and
it's very beautiful and you know you get
didn't that the great thing is that they
have comics writing articles like well
Durst and Kate Clinton well they both
write columns that's Corey and it's neat
yeah yeah well I'd like I need any more
reading material well that's it I mean
I've got books everywhere I've got books
in the bathroom i'm also actually
reading uh rereading the history of the
San Fernando Valley which I found
fascinating oh really yeah there's a
book I have that I haven't started with
supposed to be one of the best
biographies of a city which is the city
of quartz which is about Los Angeles
because I always like to know where I
live okay but at least the San Fernando
Valley book allowed me to identify the
mountains that are around us and I
insist that my children know they
mountains like range we don't even
really she ate you lease no you see the
mountains like oh yeah yeah no no those
are mountains there's mountain ranges
where I'm gonna help you know what
direction you're going and each one has
a very specific place where begins and
ends and continues to right right so
that's your fee lesson right and that's
why it's called the valley and sort you
know that law shut me out but they're
still listening a little bit as I'm
talking to them right and you're their
father yes so and yeah my father would
hold forth and it's the only way you can
really pass on information rights to
hold for that some right is the thing I
mean you know um cautious of is like is
the the amount of technology and it was
at you and i we're talking about this
talking about at the show the other
night yeah we talked about a gps yeah
and when we used when we start first got
here you had to go through the what's
that all the Thomas guide the Thomas
guide were you talking about that no we
aren't but I had a Thomas game remembers
moved here and the map it was a map book
yes
and you would go to either the next page
would it would be it would be linear it
be horizontal or you would go vertical
up and down up and down and you'd have
to go up like 45 pages just find the
next down map yes because the city was
so big and it was such a detailed map
and every year they come out with a new
Thomas guide and it was forty dollars
yep and so you could last on one Thomas
guide for about four or five years and
those those pages got well-worn and
ratted and you know you and God you
learned how to drive in los ang yes now
you know my son 16 is like do you know
where we are nope look oh he thing he
looks up from his phone yep while he's
driving Wally I'm kidding of course I'm
kidding but but that's the thing I you
know cautious or trepidatious about is
that it one satellite yeah goes down and
we can't get groceries anymore right
well and it's yeah i mean it's it's
pretty devastating the amount of its the
I travel so much and my head is inside
my iPad because I'm standing in one line
after another line I'm there for hours
on end and it's really the only thing
that's keeping me sane it's it's books
on tape and reading books and being in
my iPad and I think about I I don't have
to develop any patience anymore right
because I can just weed off and go on my
own with a pacifier it's very myself
it's sooo the [ __ ] sippy cup yep it
is it's the worst yep muggle here maybe
I'll do this maybe we'll do that bored
now yeah it's you it's it's incessant
it's nasty and what do we get done and
you know you really do have to start
monitoring yourself you know what andy
says about the GPS he's like cuz i have
that even if I know where I'm going I'll
sometimes have the waiters right yeah
and he's like you should be out out a
past the the just looking at the signs
and seeing where you are and I'm like
well the good thing about the ways in
the and the mapquest thing is that it
tells me the name of the upcoming
streets and he goes yeah there's signs
did you know right outside the window
yeah there's a sign right thing all in
3d and everything right you and I grew
up when you had to have a you
a bank of about 20 or 25 phone numbers
that you could remember offhand I can
still remember some childhood friends
and luckily my friends still live with
their parents now I could not recite to
you might and this is a sad thing my son
and daughters phone numbers you can owe
you don't even have theirs I have them
in my phone right I know it's you know I
know the first six digits right I know
my wife's right I know my husband's and
I know mice and I know my sister's cell
phone last four digits because there's
two other numbers in there and I'm like
that's a cell phone yep yeah but it's
that thing goes down we can't call each
other we don't know anything yeah I want
to do a bit about that i'm not sure
exactly where it goes but it also
totally something excellent vols
automatic towel dispensers which bother
me which i think is predicated because
there's some guy who's not qualified to
fill paper paper towels yeah you know
that guy that puts them in too tight I
and so you you can't get one ounce you
have to pull seven out which is a huge
waste yep so they said okay we can't
find a person confident enough that we
can pay a model amount of money who can
properly fill a paper towel dispenser
the right way so they keep unfolding out
that we have to invest in technology
that dispenses a paper towel to you
right in there and their desired length
I think I think it's more German someone
can't I know but someone can't steal
that bit cuz I'm gonna write it don't
steal that big that's gonna be a good
one but what I would you know with the
with the Purell and the ridiculous and
you you don't touch the water you don't
touch that's the handle answer you don't
touch anything and I'm building an
immune system myself I don't eat off the
floor that's not true I occasionally eat
off for Noah five-second rule and so
that's you scratching your beard by the
way I get all I'm so sorry that's right
but people should know David Hector has
a beard been growing it for a role hey
oh are you yeah excellent well people
should at David kettner by the way and
David character com you're gonna be
doing stand-up the first week of October
a helium in portland portland oregon
great club and then the first week of
november in salt lake city in utah at 50
west Club is that just five six and
seven is that a comedy clubs 50 west
coast i guess or is it a theater because
no not a theater which is it's a
straight stand up Moto X now they've got
two in Salt Lake the that's wise guys
right yeah I do the wise guys isn't that
I thought that's what that was 50 West
maybe that's a big cuz the year to that
one out in the suburbs and the one used
to have trolley square and they have one
out in the suburbs maybe that's the
subtitle of the Warner wiseguys yeah
maybe it's wives guys hashtag 50 West I
don't know people can google it noon ya
goin guys google it i'm too lazy I was
the last time i was in Salt Lake City so
I went out to lunch in at a vietnamese
sandwich place and three different
people told me I was in the ghetto and I
said I don't think you understand what
that word means guys it's hard to notice
the ghetto through the thriving
businesses that are all around right
without any trash no track it's a little
spooky it's I love you salt lake city
but you make me uncomfortable after day
three the first two days I feel like I'm
in a vat of warm rising bread dough
which is Marissa imagery but the of that
third day I'm so but the Wright brothers
yes are you a fair amount into it David
oh I'm probably about 80 pages and maybe
a hundred so is it start about their
childhood in their family studious so
this is just a straight by mm-hmm that's
awesome and are you reading a WC Fields
flagrant x xq yes because i love WC
Fields I love him yes he's pretty great
William Claude um what's but I don't
know what all I know about him is that
he was rude and drunk and hilarious that
was a persona ok yeah ok so you know his
you know there was a character yeah well
he did wear a hat that's all I ever want
from a character he was very I were hat
so I didn't wear one today he was very
bright very well-read but also
undereducated so he always he could he
could discourse on on abson ok the best
of them so but you know there's that a
formal education right and so I also
suffer that same thing cuz it coming
like your nephew from my a not not
rigorous childhood education share um
very rural misery yeah and so when you
do get out in the world you see how deep
people go and I think that's why I want
to read so so much you want to catch you
I want to catch up I'm with you even
though I'm almost fifty three guys still
feel like what the thing is is you're
just like I have said it before it is
just like I I
I'm like you can out white trash me you
know and you I cannot want treasure but
really almost everyone I mean the thing
is is I spent so much of my time trying
to rise above my own roots same even
though I have some connection with that
very basic upbringing that's who we are
yeah yep and why are we running from it
why don't we embrace it and go this is
something most of you don't know right
but I embrace it but I also do not want
to go back down because there is a
certain amount of foolishness to you
know like the people who celebrate their
red nekkidness yeah I'm like I celebrate
the work ethic I came from this and the
poverty in the inlet and the things that
we did to make do but I don't celebrate
the foolishness I don't I don't I don't
want to hate black people cuz they're
black right I don't embrace ignorance
yeah I don't know I I want to be smarter
than that and I and I and I do and
they're like my stepmother she was a
hairdresser and had an associate's
degree and read voraciously well and she
was just she it was her one of her
favorite jokes issues was how does a
Roman soldier order five beers and then
she would make the peace symbol and uh
nice it's a nice one listen it's a nice
way to figure out if anybody likes
knowledge or don't Wow and she was
smarter than the average bear but was
not raised she would just read a lot
yeah and she didn't read a lot of
nonfiction she read a lot of historical
fiction I love it Oh historical fiction
and those are those are fascinating to
rate depends on the amount of research
but you get some information from all it
puts you inside of and lets you live the
era and understand the all of the
parameters of what's going on culturally
socially more empty politically yes lets
you view the world dub from the top down
from the bottom up yep yeah which is a
better way to actually learn about an
era if you go if you travel with a
person yeah rather than just the facts
were so they give us we've just
discovered a new way to teach folks
which is you really should read very
good historical fiction right cuz it
puts you in the time and place where you
see it feel it here at smell it even if
they reach it e historical fiction which
I have done both yeah this should puts
you in the time and the place yeah
because you read from a soldier's point
of view that would give you the entire
geopolitical
a history of history of that era right i
was i was trying to remember there was a
i had it and if anyone remembers this
email me Jackie Jackie calm but I can't
cuz I can't i don't i think i gave away
the book but it was a mystery novel set
in the Napoleonic era well and the guy
who solved the murder was a soul of
french soldier and it was a french
writer but he wrote in english i think
and it was written from the proceeding
towards Russia Wow some so you're in the
show soldiers boots right you're in the
soldiers boots but it's also a mystery
novel and he is trying to figure out who
and it you know it could be some
nobleman who just killed this and he's a
serial killer because he keeps killing
[ __ ] as they go through different as
they go through different and he's like
that's fascinating social political
economic yeah perspective because first
of all was he was he conscripted it was
this guy is such a volunteer well it's
Napoleon so he's one of the new
bourgeois right so he's he's a with this
guy's a soldier but he's a soldier he is
a volunteer he's yeah but he's at he's
an officer but he's middle-class he's
part of the new middle class that
Napoleon cream you tell the same story
from a conscripted soldier and then it
causes less war in the future if that's
a book that children have to read early
because they realize that this person's
choice has been taken away and how
valuable it is keep make sure you always
have a choice and so you'd always voice
vote because otherwise you might allow
the draft to come back for an
imperialistic war that shouldn't happen
in the first place to protect multi
national interests I don't have opinions
right it turns out Dave Koechner's
director might also be politics I was a
poli-sci major me too hey Emily about
that where'd you go to college I went to
a small Catholic College in Atchison
Kansas called Benedict in college okay I
was conscripted because my parents said
you have to go there oh there for two
years that's your only choice for
college okay it had a familial
background storage while we I had to go
there you're Ben I could went there well
my mother's brother was the abbot of the
monastery my mother and her family very
very Catholic out of 11 children there
were two priests and two nuns out of
that bull my god particular clan yeah so
I had to go there and her sisters had
gone there
and her brothers so that was it and then
I could go anywhere I wanted after that
okay so you went to two years there and
then I went to the University of
Missouri for a year and change and
realized i didn't did you complete your
degree I did but only because my sister
it turns out is the boss of me ah she
insisted yes it's more of a philosophy
or a degree and I would have continued
but I realized I don't want to be a
politician anymore that's what I first
thought it was going to be a lawyer is
that yeah see I knew I didn't want to be
a lawyer yeah and I didn't want to i
knew i was gonna make I wasn't gonna
make the grade in politics yeah because
you either have to be wealthy or from a
political family or the smartest person
in the room of any room you walk into
that's what qualifies you to be a
politician and too bad that it's usually
not the third thing which is this
workers in the room what you say so I
realize that I'm not gonna do that I
kind of quit going to my classes yeah
not kind of i did and though i know but
that is what propelled me to go to
Chicago visit see the second city see
that they taught classes like oh that's
how a person becomes that thing I know
you got no idea how you pursue a life
and that's how you got into a sketch
comedy and stand up and all and I didn't
always started doing stand-up five years
ago okay yeah Jesus dude nice work well
thank you but I mean I've done live
forever I mean yeah I mean you started
out on the sort of second base is he at
least exactly we had performance skills
right right and commies maybe third base
but you might have started open up born
on third and but the so you did second
city did second city in a place called
the io with the time was called the
improv olympic notice is called i oh yep
that's where I started the IO and then
took classes concurrently at the second
city okay and so I had the luxury of
being in class four or five hours a week
and then would take additional workshops
with people who just start doing
workshops sometimes for free there's
that phone we're talking about earlier
time to tell the story you know I'm
we're fascinated to find out who's
calling today but so I was taking
classes all the time and I say to tell
the story all the time about the 10,000
hours theory and how i was able to
collect many hours on stage because i
was taking a lot of classes and this is
before there are multiple levels of
class
and nowadays I was all just one big
class well you'd have maybe three levels
now they have 12 so by the time you
actually get good stage time now it
takes a year or two two years I was on
stage and eight weeks and ironically I
think they're probably a lot of gifted
talented people that are not going to go
through a system because either too big
it's too big it's too expensive and so
you won't see these bright lights comedy
because of the way the irony of the
success yeah of people that came when I
was there yeah specifically that I was
there for nine years I was there with
corel Colbert Nancy walls brought Brian
stop codon writer Kevin door on the
right yeah she's awesome right Tina Fey
Amy Poehler Horatio Sanz Rachel Dratch
and you and director Jon Glaser Adam
McKay Brian McCann the chris farley all
of my guys in beer shark mice it's a
who's who of people but their success
from these institutions then engulfed
these institutions with a wealth of
students which is where they really earn
the money yeah classes the classes band
bills uh-huh and though the irony as you
can't get through yeah cuz it's too
expensive you can't get to the stage it
is so hard now because of the way things
are sort of institutionalized there's a
lot of stand-up classes and there's a
lot of sketch classes to end up classes
stand up classes I don't I you know back
in then back when I first started to
understand if there was a lot and for
many years 20 years there's been people
who've and you can do stand up without
class you can go to a thousand open mics
I learn it that way if if but if you
need a stand-up class to get on stage I
don't have a problem with that I don't
either beacon I know there's a strong
argument against it because it might
just be someone who's kouchi yes it
might just be somebody who can't make a
living doing it but then invites people
to learn and I would say the upside of
that is at least they're participating
in art and probably by having a class
and stand up somebody might go to the
theater yeah I might go to a class or
take on a risk that they wouldn't have
done without that thing that's it so it
really does inform the populace right it
informs the populace and but it also i
mean they were the best people to teach
stand up in my
opinion are people who are not good at
because not not good at it but I showed
you say but but if because what you do
is you encourage people you give them
very basic skills and and and when they
see you to stand up to some extent they
can go oh if they can do it I can do
right if they're that open if a person
that is teaching the class doesn't try
to snuff out talent because you say that
to you have teachers who are jealous of
someone else gift it goes back was that
movie uh I'm Salieri jealous of
Beethoven oh right yes Yama dancing yeah
yeah back and that can happen in any
business yes right girls person doesn't
like a mediocre talent that recognizes
great talent wants it to fail right just
be psyched you recognize it and
celebrate right right the yes nurture it
that's should and if somebody's telling
you what kind of stand-ups are right
right don't take that in rice just
because you have to write what you're
right you right everyone writes poorly
in the beginning there's nothing to be
done about it I had an amazing bit about
how Batman and Robin might be gay was
one of my first bits I don't know cuz of
the pool anyway uh done and but you
gotta I mean you have done so much jokes
yeah and everyone writes bodily
functions stuff and they write just crap
and eventually Aristotle wrote it come
on mm-hmm and so eventually you find
stuff that's very much your own and
that's the stuff that really shines
right whatever is funny to you then then
you the audience agrees with you like
okay yep nowhere then you just keep
writing yeah just keep uh yeah not
stealing bread II don't yeah and don't
steal cuz there's no point to there's no
point you'll be found out and then and
it's just it's it's it's not that it's
lazy because it actually takes more work
to steal from other people it's
genuinely you're you're you're you're
hurting yourself cuz there's there's
there's good stuff in everybody there's
there's amazing work inside of you you
don't have to steal screw it don't worry
about it yeah it's a Tom papa right now
has the greatest premise in the world
that I accidentally did I just set it
out loud on stage one time and then I
had to call him and go hey I did have
for your new joke and I'm so sorry
so did you know before you did her you
realize after in mid-sentence and then I
the premise is the greatest premise ever
and what he said on stage was
tampabay.com and ever is that he said
that his wife was crazy and she was
crazy because that is the job of him and
his children is to drive her crazy aha
and because all mothers are crazy and my
premises is that my mother is crazy and
the it's same [ __ ] premise I can't do
it anyway is that is that I would always
think how crazy my stepmother was but
the reason she was crazy was because she
was crazy she had been driven mad and um
Tom Pappas theory was that his wife is
the only person in their house who wakes
up knowing that there's work to do
everyone else wakes up and so she's the
only one who wakes up going well we
gotta eat and we got to get the kids to
school and we gotta put your shoes up
and so by that time that she is fully
awake she's yelling uh-huh and everyone
is going well we just woke up right why
are you yelling she's not yeah yeah
she's ten miles down the road right and
she's like someone has to care and Tom
is like so him and his kids just roll
their eyes at each other and she goes
mad and and it's the greatest premise in
the world and i wish i could but what
was your bed with my biet was about how
it took me so long to appreciate the
fact that the reason my mother was crazy
was because we had driven her mad I i
think there's there's plenty of ways to
slice that same premise though it
doesn't sound like her yeah Tom said you
know just find a different way to to get
into it then you're fine yeah and so I
haven't yet found a place but but I
loved that it was a freakin epiphany
when he said it out loud that's great
comedy yeah that's great comedy no it is
when you then he loves you yeah things
fire and people other people synapses
while you were talking yeah yeah that's
the fun woman so you don't just read and
for the love of God let us talk to David
okay so what about the Johnny Rotten bio
I that was given to me for free and so I
started I read the first chapter he's a
musical person yes yeah Johnny Rotten
was with the Sex Pistols here we go and
then public image limited okay
I think the name of the book is rise
which is public image limited uh most
probably the most famous song okay which
is Anchorage in energy you may be wrong
u-boat which by the way oddly enough
quince identity enough I saw they're
going back on tour oh really well oh
that's Larry yeah yeah yeah so I started
that one cuz it was given to me in like
I'll start reading this now yeah I think
I was given to me at a radio station so
I went back to my room at the hotel when
I was touring and yep started reading it
and then I put that down range is more
stuff to carry around and what else was
on the pickup story by rap Robert McKee
well that's one yeah you know if you're
gonna write a screenplay oh yeah it's oh
it's a it's a learning one yeah oh
that's kind of neat though and it is it
good it's great and you're listening to
the war of art right anytime you're
stuck i would suggest it uh Pressman
it's basically get this stuff even
Pressfield yeah press field yeah that's
it I think there might be another one by
another guy that I'm reading no Cole
Pressman but Pressfield he's a prolific
writer okay and I agree with his premise
of you know your enemy is resistance so
don't resist it it's like you you know
just the art you just let it go or well
we all when we don't do something you
have the resistance and I think the
lower the the deeper premise to that
thing is whatever you're resisting gives
you some anxiety so don't have it cuz
anxiety doesn't exist if you don't
create it okay it might not some of its
real for some people because there might
have been to trauma an I'm not
suggesting that that's not real no but
but if you can process it correctly yes
which is easier to say than do obviously
but if you can you can get rid of
anxiety just because of how well he does
that's not his premises necessarily but
that's where I go to with the the the
the war of art not the art of war the
war of art because you know just
whatever you feel resistance and we have
it all day long yeah you need to find
out what that is and just open it up
yeah and get past that that'll be
awesome don't resist cuz you're standing
in your own way this yes said yeah which
I argue in show business there's only
one person standing in your way and it
is you cuz there's many times and show
business people like well that guy's got
my job or that girl got my job or no one
got your job no I got you no one got
your job you didn't get the job because
of you right and there's the other work
so don't worry about and all you can do
is keep doing what you do and that now
how does that fit into my theory my
theory is all you can do is do it you do
as well as you can do it and then sort
of do the next indicated action but if
you don't ever get the job that you
wanted to some extent I think and this
sounds a little hippie skippy but I'm
like I don't think that I was meant to
get that job I grew that and it doesn't
matter i use it as long as i can let go
to the point where I'm like well I'm
maybe I'm not meant to have that gag I
have these other gauges that's already
over yeah why are we where are we
focusing on that right life has already
moved ahead right to do the next thing
do the next thing you're already doing
it right yeah you know this my wife is
getting her master's in spiritual
psychology so often there's a plenty of
those books lying around and discussions
to be had about you know but there's an
idea that who you are right now this
second is not the same you that was
there two seconds ago right so you're
always someone new and you're always
linked to a different power and there's
there's a center of you that's always a
higher relevance because your body just
changed because you're dying we're all
dying all right we're all growing and
dying in all of that stuff yeah but
there's something that's a piece of God
that lizzo or whatever divinity you
choose to make it the energy that you
came from yep is always there was always
that high seat part of you mm-hmm and
that's what she's a focus on not like do
I need to get my haircut should i buy
these clothes why didn't I get that job
right and you think about that instance
and how whatever this universe that
we've been granted to be partaking in
yeah is a higher seat that we should be
seeking anyway yeah and not you know
focus on me longing beheading people
yeah right you focus on like sort of
your height whatever your higher power
is your God or whatever right and and
and not worry about sort of oh wait a
minute I read this in the Bible one time
it's like is that the gut will take care
even though even the sparrow in the
field or some damn thing there's those
there's all of those which is um there's
some quote of you know I'm a lily I'm a
lily of the field that's it because it's
a Frank Capra quote from from you can't
take it with you ah which is a Frank
Capra it's a it who was in It's a
Wonderful Life
Jimmy Stewart Jimmy sure it was I so
it's a Jimmy Stewart moving Frank Capra
as well and um it is a great movie it's
one of its one of its a great play but
it's one of my favorite movies well
anyway the point being yeah like your
point which was you can only do what you
do yeah and nothing it doesn't matter
about what other or not someone else did
right it's happening for you right now
so go ahead and participate in it rather
than look back right and worry about
what you could have done it earlier he
doesn't exist unless we created it right
as well yeah it's a yeah you know it's
interesting because Andy doesn't have
any of that training but he kind of
lives in the moment anyway and he
doesn't he like I'm constantly worried
about money and I'm constantly and if
you worry about money yeah it brings
more worried right and that's that thing
and I know but people go what are you
guys talking about but money's an idea
at the same time money is an idea right
it's not good to donate guys money but
money doesn't exist okay ownership just
an idea yeah yeah ownership doesn't
exist right that's an agreement we all
make that yes that person owns that
building or that boss owns my labor
right those are all ideas and really
that that shouldn't it's all gonna work
out it's all gonna work out which is
Andy's motto aunty ashcraft goes through
life going no I'm just gonna because his
did when he was a kid his dad told him
never work for a living eventually
they'll pay you to do what you like to
do anyway perfect and so and you know
what his father did until he died which
was he trained bird dogs for field
trials well from horseback and you're
like well that is the coolest weirdo job
in the world and you fell into it and he
probably enjoyed it and enjoyed it yeah
before that he was a navigator on for
United Airlines Wow and he just fell
into that yeah and you it's not about
accumulating things cuz someone's gonna
be save you accumulate palaces your
houses that are surrounded by ponds it
doesn't matter cuz some smartass comic
somebody staying at it eventually anyway
mocking your existence exactly i'm gonna
hit golf balls into your pond anyway did
you yeah that's awesome super fun anyway
David kick nur it has been an hour I
could talk to you for another hour is
there anything is that what what's your
favorite book that you've read in the
last year or so that you might wreck
men that any of these that you'd
recommend people get on I mean the war
of art obviously I'm gonna actually get
the audio because I do love an audio I
love ya because you can listen to it
editing anytime soon yeah I'm enjoying
the Wright brothers book you know what
book i want to read and i'm fascinated
by is the nixon book it's about hit up
Nixon versus the world or something like
that I can't believe it's on the not on
the New York Times bestseller list
that's fascinating i watch that
documentary about Nixon move on nixon
then nixon frost/nixon tapes oh the
Nixon tapes how they they just fulfilled
that okay yeah it's fascinating what the
man was going through and his president
united states in it it's it's
mind-blowing that this guy was in charge
of things was he related to somebody
famous did he have a lot of money or was
he the smartest man in the room smartest
man in the room Nixon was a very bright
man yeah and very very very um I will
say conniving but um just shrewd shrewd
thank you clever mm-hmm-hmm very
paranoid and paranoid is all hell I uh I
remember cuz my poli sci degree
southeast asian studies wow I no
particular reason I was up for that I
had a friend to his Indonesian I was
always fascinated with Vietnam right in
the Vietnam War and again why did we do
it right but we really believe in the
Red Scare yeah and that that Russia if
we if Vietnam fell it was all gonna go
that would like they we thought that was
the linchpin well everyone believe I'm
een it's it's the way they scare you
into the next thing they're like if you
allow gay marriage people are going to
marry their cats right and so I I you
know I not to get a politics but you had
to appreciate the restraint of going
into Iraq again now with this horrible
scourge that is Isis because you don't
want to get drunk we've been fighting
over there for 20 yeah [ __ ] years
yeah what did we do uh we just hold a
lot of people killed a lot of people and
that guy who was our ally and was a
horrible horrible person Saddam Hussein
is now gone and there's worse it's Hydra
is essentially though there's a million
of them we had an opportunity after nine
eleven and Noam Chomsky talks about yes
saying that had we made it a police
action to find one man who did the bad
deed
which is Osama bin Laden the world would
have joined us they were all on our side
at that point right we wouldn't
Afghanistan we made a base everyone I'm
just gonna fly in one guy we're not
going after everybody yeah I even
supported going into Afghanistan
Afghanistan yes I believe that as well
and then I was like and now get out now
we got a two front or I red flash Minh
did you ever read Watchmen George
MacDonald I it's uh it's one of the
donkey don't give me a book ok I will
not give you a book but people have i've
talked about flash Jackie just pointed
to a book on her bookshelf yeah you rite
of your red flash Minh like you know I
she's either gonna give me a t-shirt or
a book to take home I'm definitely
giving you a t-shirt I can I've already
read the t-shirt I've can read that
entire thing with one glance that's
beautiful except for that the bottom of
that dork for us that that's elvish it's
what Aragorn says when he finds the
white tree at the end of the return of
the king that's a Bret Bret chambers
that was fan art that dork forest love
nice and then the black one that's the
Ranger of the dark forest t-shirt that
has dorky things coming out of it that
my nephew did and I and II designed the
spooky reading girl teacher but you get
to pick one David kaktor you guys go out
see one of his movies go see a stand-up
at Portland Oregon follow him on twitter
at David kettner and thanks for
listening and you know the rules take
care of each other my hat my hat my hat
they're dancing around my hat hat my hat
my hat well what do you think of that if
it looks like a Mexican Hat dance and it
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a Mexican Hackett so take
off your head and let stand oh my god we
why don't we just call that at the end
of the show